it's hard to imagine that the man
responsible for the nazi's deadly v2
weapon was also responsible for nasa's
majestic saturn v rocket we have a
liftoff lift up on apollo 11. werner von
braun is one of the most controversial
scientists in history he wasn't just any
scientist at nasa he was the scientist
who got us to the moon
so how did the man who worked for adolf
hitler become an american hero
von braun was born on march 23 1912 in
the small town of virzits in present-day
poland which was then part of the german
empire when he was young the brown
family settled in berlin where his
father worked at the ministry of the
interior he came from a wealthy
aristocratic family his mother
encouraged his curiosity by giving him a
telescope when he was a teenager it
helped fuel his interest in astronomy
and space
you think that as a rocket scientist he
would have aced math and physics but
actually he didn't do all that well at
school at least not at first
the turning point came when he read the
rocket into planetary space by rocket
pioneer hermann oberg and decided to
apply himself to calculus and
trigonometry so he could master the
physics of rocketry while studying
mechanical engineering at the technical
university of berlin von braun joined an
amateur rocket association and caught
the attention of the german army which
recognized his talent they offered to
finance his phd research if he helped
develop liquid fuel rockets for the
military he got his doctorate in 1934 a
year after hitler came to power with war
on hitler's mind rocketry became a top
priority for the german government and
who better to lead the program than von
braun whose ambitions were out of this
world
while a student he attended a
presentation by swiss physicist auguste
picab famous for his hydrogen balloon
flights
afterward von braun approached pika and
said you know i plan on traveling to the
moon at some time pika is said to have
responded with encouragement
although he would never go to space
himself von braun is responsible for
getting the first humans to the moon on
the apollo 11 mission in 1969
at the time the american public knew
very little if anything about his past
as a member of the nazi party and an ss
officer there was no existing photo of
von braun in which you can clearly see
him in his uniform the closest is this
photo of him wearing the nazi party
badge on his suit lapel although even
this isn't all that clear the us
government largely hid his background
until after his death he was among
hundreds of german scientists engineers
and technicians recruited as part of
operation paperclip at the end of world
war ii although president truman forbade
recruiting nazi members or supporters
u.s intelligence agencies eliminated or
whitewashed incriminating evidence of
possible war crimes from their records
one brown was the star recruit he was
the brains behind the nazis v2 ballistic
missile the first object to go into
space defined as 62 vertical miles out
or 100 kilometers and effectively
launched the space age von braun led the
team that developed the v2 at a secret
laboratory at pinamunda located on a
northern german island from there they
built and tested the rockets by
launching them into the baltic sea
the v in v2 stands for the german word
vergel tongswaffen which means vengeance
this was vengeance weapon number two
v2s attacked allied cities in
retaliation for the allied bombings
against german cities
they were used in the latter stages of
the war and were a last-ditch effort by
the germans to ward off defeat the v2
was a totally new kind of weapon it was
the world's first large-scale liquid
propellant rocket instead of weapons
with a hundred pounds of thrust it had
55 000 pounds of thrust the nazis
launched over 3000 v2s equipped with a
one-ton warhead targeting western europe
mostly britain and belgium they flew at
more than 3 000 miles an hour or 4 800
kilometers an hour and could reach
london in five minutes because they came
in at over three times the speed of
sound the v2 made absolutely no sound
until after it hit so it crashed and
exploded without warning it is estimated
to have killed between 5 000 to 9 000
civilians and soldiers yet more than
twice as many people are believed to
have died producing them the nazis
forced prisoners from concentration
camps to build the rockets at the
middlework factory underneath a mountain
in central germany to avoid enemy air
attacks prisoners did 12 hours a day of
back-breaking work pushing heavy
equipment in areas filled with dust and
noxious gases from the blasting to widen
the tunnels conditions were far worse
than depicted in this nazi propaganda
photo they slept in the tunnels they dug
their only toilets or oil barrels cut in
half with boards over them because there
wasn't enough many relieved themselves
in the tunnels the stench was
intolerable starvation and poor hygiene
exacerbated outbreaks of typhoid and
tuberculosis the nazis recruited
prisoners who had technical skills such
as welding to build the rockets those
accused of sabotaging their production
were hanged from cranes above the rocket
assembly lines when von braun was later
asked by a reporter if he was aware of
the slave labor that built the v2s he
said well you're misinformed the slave
camp was about 400 miles from where i
worked i learned later on that there
were atrocities taking place there but i
was not involved in this whole operation
i have nothing to hide i have nothing to
hide
however historians are certain von braun
saw the horrific conditions with his own
eyes michael j neufeld author of the
book von braun dreamer of space engineer
of war found through his research that
von braun was in the tunnels at least a
dozen times newfeld said that when von
braun testified at a war crimes trial in
west germany in the late 60s he
mentioned he'd been through the
underground sleeping quarters von braun
later claimed in interviews that he
really had no choice but to join the
nazis i believe you were forced to join
the nazi party as i understand it no
this isn't quite right uh oh um
uh we understand you uh you would like
to join the party
and he has a form an application form
but the circumstances were such that
uh
the message would have been very loud
and clear you know how do you not send
it in
he continued to stick to the line that
he was simply a scientist who wanted to
pursue the noble goal of going to space
he would later recall that he never
liked hitler referring to him as a
pompous fool with a charlie chaplin
mustache
he was also vocal about the fact that he
was arrested by nazi germany's secret
police the gestapo in march 1944 after
he went to a party and while drunk
allegedly said he foresaw the war ending
badly for germany this was akin to
treason and he was imprisoned for about
two weeks until hitler's men released
him to continue producing v2s the
following year in 1945 germany
surrendered von braun had been planning
for the post-war era and went south to
american occupied territory in the alps
where he made the shrewd decision to
surrender
the americans were more than happy to
snap up the brilliant mind behind
germany's advanced military arsenal the
us and the soviet union had never seen
anything like it they captured many v2s
for research to develop their own space
programs propelling the former allies
into an arms race in the 50s for 15
years after the war von braun worked
with the us army to develop ballistic
missiles and launch vehicles first in
texas before being stationed in
huntsville alabama
while settled in america he sailed to
europe in 1947 to bring back a bride he
married his first cousin maria in
southeastern germany he was 35 she was
18. they had three children now here's a
model my design for four-stage orbital
rocket ship von braun became one of the
most prominent advocates of space
exploration in the 50s and was even
featured in a disney tv show on space
travel
in 1958 president eisenhower created the
national aeronautics and space
administration nasa a federal agency
dedicated to space exploration the us
didn't want to fall behind the soviets
who surprised everyone by launching
sputnik the world's first artificial
satellite and man-made object into
earth's orbit in 1957.
the following year america answered by
putting its first satellite into space
explorer is in orbit under the direction
of von braun and his team america's
ambitions would be even bigger
president john f kennedy gave america
the ultimate challenge
i believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal
before this decade is out
of landing a man on the moon and
returning him safely to the earth
von braun became the chief architect of
the saturn v rocket that would propel
americans to the lunar surface on july
20 1969
[Music]
11 also fulfilled von braun's lifelong
ambition though he would have loved to
have gone to space himself
in 1970 when he was prepared to leave
huntsville to take a job with nasa in
washington he addressed a crowd and said
my friends there was dancing in the
streets of huntsville when our first
satellite orbited earth there was
dancing again when the first americans
landed on the moon
i'd like to ask you
don't hang up your dancing slippers
he left nasa two years later to work at
a private aerospace manufacturing
company he continued to work even after
being diagnosed with kidney cancer
the cancer caught up with him and he was
too ill to attend the white house when
president gerald ford awarded him the
country's highest science honor the
national medal of science in 1975.
two years later on june 16 1977
he died of cancer at a hospital in
alexandria virginia
he was 65 years old
von braun was known for two achievements
that were polar opposites one was part
of hitler's inhumanity
the other a giant leap for humanity
it's easy to label someone a hero or a
villain to see things as black and white
but real life is complicated and so was
von braun
what was clear is that above all else
von braun loved space
while a student he read an article
imagining a trip to the moon and
recalled it filled me with a romantic
urge interplanetary travel here was a
task worth dedicating one's life to not
just stare through a telescope at the
moon in the planets but to soar through
the heavens and actually explore the
mysterious universe i knew how columbus
had felt
von braun achieved his dream because of
his determination to master calculus and
trigonometry so he could understand the
physics of rocketry if you'd like to
improve your stem skills brilliant is my
go-to platform to improve my critical
thinking and problem-solving skills and
it's free for you to try out i know my
viewers love the scientific thinking
course where you can explore the laws of
physics and the principles of
engineering by learning as you play i
really like that it's super interactive
there's something for everyone on
brilliant no matter your age or
experience level you can start your
algebra journey with an introduction to
variables and equations with their
pre-algebra course or begin your math
journey by seeing fractions percents and
ratios in everyday contexts with their
everyday math course if you're ever
stuck on a problem you can view the
explanation for more brilliant is free
for you to try out if you head to my
custom link brilliant.org newsthink
which is in my description and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription which gives you access to
all of their course offerings
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm